So far, we have discussed disorders that affect both thought and behavior.
However, there're some disorders that actually take on bodily or physical form
and actually mimic diseases. This is called Somatic Symptom Disorder. Somatic
Symptom Disorder used to be called hypochondriasys and is occurs when a person
complains of multiple physical disorders that cause distress and distruption of
a person's life. And persists for at least 6 months. According to the APA,
there are two main criteria for diagnosis. First, one or more distressing
somatic systems that disrupt daily living. And second, excessive thoughts,
feelings or behaviors related to bodily symptoms. Approximately 5 to 7% of US
adults experience Somatic Symptom Disorder. A very similar disorder is known as
Illness Anxiety Disorder. And it also involves a preoccupation and anxiety over
having illnesses. But without any of the actual symptoms.